I think it's a truism in science that if
you can see something you can study it
what's really exciting about GFP is it's
allowed us to see so much within the
cells that we were not aware of before
could GFP be made in something other
than the jellyfish and by far the
easiest way of looking at this would be
to put it into bacteria and so that was
the first experiment when Ghia actually
started to do the experiment there were
obviously several steps that needed to
be done
isolate that the original DNA make many
copies of it by polymerase chain
reaction take that DNA and transform or
add that DNA to bacteria so that each
bacterium got one copy of the DNA grow
up those bacteria and look at it under a
microscope that would allow you to see
fluorescence the first was to take the
DNA that Douglas pressure had provided
us and to make lots of copies of it and
I wanted her only to use the coding
sequence but the original DNA that
Douglas had given us had not only the
coding sequence but some extra jellyfish
DNA on either side I just didn't want to
have anything extra I just wanted to
have what we needed so we used the
method of polymerase chain reaction PCR
which starts by having pieces of DNA
primers that will bind to specific parts
of the DNA and allow that part of the
DNA to be copied and amplified so that
if you get many copies of it so we were
careful in the sense that we just wanted
to use the coding sequence I had two
samples one we're ecoli with the plasmid
or also known as a vector which had the
GFP insert and then another tube of
e.coli that only had plasmid no GFP
insert
there's a little fuzzy because no one
had really done this out and really
looked at GFP outside its native
jellyfish it was important to have that
control of e.coli that weren't
expressing gfp and so you could see that
there was a difference in fluorescence
between the two as fairly stunned at the
time because the whole experiment wasn't
supposed to be that easy so it was
really surprising it actually worked and
so that first day in October about a
month after she started graduate school
gia was able to look down the microscope
and actually see bacteria that were
glowing green when they were stimulated
by blue light our conclusion was it
doesn't need anything else
it works completely on its own this is
going to be a very useful way of marking
cells and proteins
you